This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Otto Lilienthal was a 19th century design engineer who was fascinated by the idea of flying machines. He meticulously studied the shape of the wings of birds and invented a flying apparatus that allowed him to glide short distances. On Sunday, August 9th, 1896, Otto went to a hilly region about 50 miles from where he lived in Berlin. He strapped into his glider like a human stork and took three successful flights. But on his fourth attempt,
a strong gust of wind launched Otto up about 50 feet and then careened him toward the earth. He tried to wrestle the glider out of a crash but failed to do so. The plunge broke Otto's neck. He died shortly afterwards. A few years later, two bicycle mechanics in Ohio realized what was wrong with Otto's glider. It required the pilot to move his body to change the center of gravity of the machine. This system gave the pilot limited balance and control. It would be like trying to maneuver a bicycle only by leaning to one side or another.
Orville and Wilbur Wright knew a great deal about balance and control from their work on bicycles. While idly twisting a cardboard box one day, the brothers realized they could warp the shape of a fixed wing through a set of wires. In effect, they could provide a pilot with a handlebar. Tests confirmed that this system provided significantly more control than Otto's glider. The rest, of course, is history. Otto Lilienthal had built a machine that mimicked the mechanics of birds.
He was an actual engineer. The Wright brothers borrowed from the much more unlikely source of bicycle physics. The history of invention is full of stories like this. People who have knowledge and training and skills can find themselves stuck. And then someone comes out of left field and solves the problem. Today, we take a close look at the process of creativity. Insights and epiphanies often seem to arise without explanation. But researchers increasingly find
there is a science to generating them. The alchemy of invention, this week on Hidden Brain. We all have problems. Whether it's trying to solve a complex issue at work, or figuring out how to get your toddler dressed in the morning, all of us grapple with challenges big and small. On the bright side, these problems often come with aha moments. You're on a walk or in the shower when boom, a big idea or a brilliant solution appears out of nowhere. Where do epiphanies come from? And what can we do to make them appear more frequently, more predictably? At Columbia University, social psychologist Sheena Iyengar has spent many years studying the surprising origin of powerful ideas. Sheena
Iyengar, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. Sheena, on September 13th, 1940, a large steam ship named the SS City of Benares left the United Kingdom on a 2,500 mile voyage. Who was on board, Sheena, and where was the ship headed? There were about 400 people on this ship. They were Britishers, and they were headed to Canada. Why were they leaving the United Kingdom in the middle of World War Two? Well, this was at a point of British history during the war
where they were really in a bad situation. It looked like they were going to lose. And so they were very in a bad situation. It looked like they were gonna lose. And so they were very quickly trying to evacuate a large number of particularly children. The original plan was to evacuate around 210,000 children. Wow. But they were just trying to get the children out of the way before bombing started,
so that the adults would be ready to fight. So around this time, the Germans had drawn something of a chokehold around shipping lanes to and from England. How had they done this, Sheena? Well essentially, no food or military supplies or fuel could come in and out of England because the Germans had these U-boats, which were boats that could be on top but could also go underwater, at which point they could very stealthily, you know, torpedo the Allied ships. And they were just very good at this. the Allied ships. And they were just very good at this.
The Allies had better accuracy in being able to launch torpedoes, but that every time they would launch a torpedo, their communications would get jammed because the Germans had really good technology at that time for jamming the communications, and they would essentially intercept the torpedoes. So they wouldn't get hurt, but they would manage to take down many allied ships.
So four days into this voyage, a panic breaks out on the ship. It's been torpedoed by a German U-boat. Do we have any accounts of what that was like on the ship that night, Sheena? It was pretty terrible. It was a rough weather that night as well. And so even the people that did manage to get into those lifeboats, even those, many of them did still die
because the waters were quite rough. Somewhere around 80 children potentially died. We don't have the exact numbers, but an upwards of about 250 people died in total. So this tragedy makes news all over the world, and it catches the attention of a woman named Hedy Lamarr. We may need a minute to back up and explain who Hedy Lamarr was. I understand she has an interesting backstory that starts in Vienna, Austria?
Yes, Hedy Lamarr was born in 1914. She was a very famous actress and when she's about 17, 18 years old, maybe 19 years old, she is married to an Austrian arms provider who becomes her first husband. And so she, a Jew, becomes the wife of somebody who provides arms to the Germans and the Italians. And so at these dinners that her husband would host, she would learn a lot about weaponry that was being used by the Nazis. Wow. And so even though she wouldn't be allowed to speak at these dinners, she was actually absorbing all of that information. And it's said that she even helped advise her husband at night, you know, when people were gone about his business dealings. Now, of course, over time,
it's obviously becoming more and more anti-Semitic. She's feeling more and more uncomfortable with this. And so she runs away. She's obviously beautiful. She already is known as an actress, so she does get picked up by Hollywood producers, MGM, and takes a ship from London and goes to Hollywood. Wow. So she's now working in Hollywood.
She's widely seen as a star and sometimes described as the most beautiful woman in the world. But because of her backstory, she also wants to help defeat Nazi Germany. She hears about the sinking of the SS city of Benares and she talks about it with her friend George Anteil. Was George Anteil also an entertainer, Sheena? Well, he was a composer and piano player. He was the son of German immigrants, so he was an American, but he certainly
had a German heritage. They both learn about what just happened. They're both distressed. They're friends. And they are also people that happen to, as a hobby, play duets together on the piano. She was also an accomplished pianist when growing up in Vienna. Legend has it that Hetty and George were sitting at the piano one day,
when they got an idea that would appear to be well outside their area of expertise. How to keep the Nazi U-boats from jamming Allied radio signals and sinking their ships. So let's keep in mind that Hetty does know something about the German technology and how it was able to jam the communications between the allies. She's now doing a duet, so she also knows about music, and so does George. And as they play, they both have this inspiration, or flash of insight you might say. Hey look, we're both playing different keys,
and yet we're in tune, and we know what we're doing, and it's flowing seamlessly. And that's because we both know what song we're playing, even though we are using different chords, we're holding on to the same rhythm. holding onto the same rhythm. So we're able to do this with great synchrony. And so the question is, wait, if we could do that with music, is that something we could do with communications that would travel via radio? And how would this work? So you have these two musicians now who are now playing the same song,
and because they know they're playing the same song, even though they're in different keys, they can stay in sync with one another. How would this work with torpedoes and communications between allied ships? So the way the allied ships would send communications, right? So you're an allied ship and you're sending a torpedo to do damage to this U-boat that's headed your way. And as you're sending the communication for this torpedo to head towards the U-boat, what does the U-boat do? It intercepts and jams that communication. And that's because the communication between the allies and the torpedo are going along one frequency, or we could say like one, you know, one chord. And so their insight was, what if, what if we were to transmit the message from one radio
What if we were to transmit the message from one radio to a transmitter to a receiver in a way that it keeps moving? Just like music can keep moving, so it's essentially hopping, while it would appear like garbage to somebody else, to the people who know what the message is and what it's trying to do, they would be able to follow it along. So it'll keep hopping in synchrony. So in other words, instead of transmitting just on one frequency, if I keep changing my frequency as I'm sending my message, but
you know the order in which I'm going to be changing frequencies, you can keep up, the message comes through, but someone trying to jam any one frequency is not going to have any success jamming my message. That's right. It's like a constantly changing symphony, and they refer to it as frequency hopping. Now it's worth pointing out of course that George Anteil was the son of German immigrants, as you said, and Hedy Lamarr was from Austria. When they go to the US Navy to say, we've come up with a way to fight Nazi U-boats, what happens, Sheena?
Well, they get a patent and then they take it to the Navy, and the Navy actually decides that they're spies and they didn't do anything with it. It could have actually saved a lot of lives, but they didn't do anything with it. They just didn't trust it. So, Harry Lamar's invention is not used during the Second World War, but I understand that 20 years later the military sort
of wisens up? Yeah, they used it during the Cuban Missile Crisis. And it is an amazing invention. I mean, it is the basis behind Bluetooth, GPS. It wouldn't have been possible without this. Heri Lamar died in 2000. She was 85 years old. Along with George Antile, she was inducted posthumously into the National Inventors Hall of Fame in 2014. Solutions to complex problems sometimes come out of nowhere. Who would think two people playing a piano have anything useful to say about halting Nazi submarines?
When we come back, the science and the psychology behind like-bought moments. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. When we think of aha moments, we tend to think of them as miracles. Isaac Newton watched an apple fall from a tree, and bam, he came up with a theory of gravity. The Greek mathematician Archimedes lowered himself into a relaxing bath and came up with insights about density and buoyancy. He's said to have jumped out of the bath and came up with insights about density and buoyancy. He's said to have jumped out of the bath and run naked through the streets,
exclaiming, Eureka, or I have found it. At Columbia University Business School, psychologist Sheena Iyengar has studied the steps that lead to light bulb moments. Sheena, I want you to walk us through some of the components that you say are behind big ideas, and I want to use an iconic example. Many of us today marvel at the Statue of Liberty. We think it's meaningful, that it represents a powerful vision of the United States of America.
We think of it as being a beacon of hope and freedom. But the story of the Statue of Liberty actually starts in a small town in France in the middle of the 19ue of Liberty actually starts in a small town in France in the middle of the 19th century. A young man named Frédéric Auguste Bartholdi seems to have had artistic talent, so his mom moves the family to Paris to give him more opportunities. Can you tell me Frédéric Bartholdi's story? So Frédéric Bartholdi was born in the countryside of France. When he was two, his father passed away. And shortly thereafter, his mom moved them to Paris because she noticed that Frederick had some real artistic talent,
and she wanted to give him those opportunities. And so he was raised in Paris, and he learned the skills of art, and in particular, sculpting. When he was a young man, he was among a group of artists that was selected and they were sent to Egypt. Then he was mesmerized by the colossal sculptures that were guarding the ancient Egyptian tombs. So some years later, after he returns to France, he hears about an interesting project involving the Suez Canal. Tell me a little bit about this. The Suez Canal was being built and they put out a call for sculptors.
Well, they put out a call for proposals so that people could suggest a sculpture that would be put there. And you know, the idea was this was gonna be at the opening of the Suez Canal, and they invited lots of different proposals, and Frederick Bartholdi submitted a proposal for a colossal woman, dressed in robes, carrying a light, he called it the light to Asia. Despite having collected
multiple proposals in the end, they decided to just build a small lighthouse there, which is what stands there today. So the Suez Canal project goes nowhere, but Frédéric Bartholdi returns to Paris and he gets in touch with a friend of his. And this friend of his has an idea about a statue that he wants built in America. Why America, Sheena? Well, as we know, you know, the French have this way of creating republics and then dissolving them. He wants to try to restore the faith of the French people in freedom
and democracy. So at this point, you know, the United States is actually proving to be a much better success story than the French. So he has this idea that in order to restore the French people's faith in freedom and democracy, he's going to build a statue and give that as a gift to the United States, honoring the 100 years of the Declaration of Independence. And then he asks Frederic Bartholdy to build the statue. And what is the idea that Frederick Bartholdy comes up with? Well, we all know what Lady Liberty looks like. And so the question is, where did Frederick Bartholdy get the idea of Lady Liberty?
Well, certainly the idea of this colossal statue comes, you can see that in his initial proposal that he submitted for the Suez Canal. While he's building this sculpture, getting the idea, at that time there was a very famous painting that was hanging in Museo de Orsay and it was this painting called L'Averite by the famous painter Laveve. Now L'Averite means the lady of truth and if you were to see this painting the lady of truth has some similarities so the positioning is very similar to la vérité. Now comes the crown. Now the French were really enamored of concepts like liberty, right? And so the seal for the second republic was Libertas, the Roman goddess. And that was actually probably jingling in Bartoli's pocket in the form of a five-franc
coin, which had Libertas on it. And then finally, when you look at the face of Lady Liberty, many people have commented on the likeness between the face of Lady Liberty and the face of the most important woman in Bartoldi's life, and that was his mother. And when he was asked whether that was the face of his mother, he did not deny it. Wow. So to summarize, a French artist draws on Egyptian sculptures to design something
for the Suez Canal. When that plan falls through, he teams up with a friend in France to raise money for a sculpture in America. He draws on a local coin and his mother's face to design the sculpture, but the story doesn't end there. Today, we see the statue, especially with its location in New York Harbor, as a symbol of hope for immigrants and refugees.
How did that transformation come about, Sheena? Yeah, that's interesting, right? Because certainly when you look at Lady Liberty, there is a broken shackle at her feet, which is supposed to commemorate the abolition of slavery. But yet, as you're correct, it came to become a symbol of freedom that was more than freedom from slavery. Now at the unveiling, there was a woman by the name of Emma Lazarus.
Emma was a descendant of Spanish and Portuguese refugees. They were Jews, they were escaping the Inquisition, and she's asked to write something for the opening. Now, she draws on her family's experience and essentially writes that famous poem, you know, that we all associate with Lady Liberty, who welcomes the yearning masses to her golden threshold. She writes that poem, and that is read at the time of the unveiling. So you have Lady Liberty, and now you have a poem that is giving it an interpretation, a meaning. Now, the poem actually may not have gone anywhere, but
years later, around early 1900s, the great grandchild of Alexander Hamilton, you know, wants to sort of give even more meaning and more attention to Lady Liberty. She finds the poem written by Emma Lazarus collecting dust in an old bookstore. And she then essentially was responsible for having the poem hung on the pedestal upon which Lady Liberty now stands. Wow. on the pedestal upon which Lady Liberty now stands. And I think if you put those pieces together, right, the story of the sculpture, the poem,
then its association with the original forefathers, and as you know, Hamilton himself was an immigrant who came here for refuge. And so if you put these pieces together, you have what becomes a very powerful symbol of hope and freedom. And certainly her location ends up welcoming the yearning masses that come from all across the globe
seeking refuge in New York's harbor. You know, it's striking, She Sheena I've seen the Statue of Liberty a few times and it's really you know so dramatic so iconic and of course when I think of it I have all these associations already in my head but really what you're showing here is that this was less of one you know magic moment of epiphany and more about a series of recombinations of past ideas and past events. Sure, one person has one combination and then the next person creates a new
combination and then the next person takes those combinations and recombines it again and that's how you get a really big idea. A big idea is not just one person. The one person might have the inspiration, they create the initial combination. But in order for that initial combination to go places, you essentially need other people to be able to see that idea and reimagine the potential of that idea. And that's how it scales.
Now, of course, lots of people had seen giant Egyptian sculptures before Frederick Bartholdi, but he did not just look, he actually noticed something. He filed it away in his memory. You tell another wonderful story about the power of observation. In the late 19th century, a physical education teacher in Springfield College, Massachusetts was dealing with a problem. James Nasimid students played football, baseball, lacrosse, rugby, and soccer, but in the winter
they were all cooped up. How did he solve this problem, Sheena? So he was basically a gym teacher and he was given a task by his boss to do the following. He had a whole bunch of teenagers, we all know what teenagers are like, and he had to get rid of their energy. And so he needed to make sure that he created a sport that could be done indoors, because this was in the winter and it's Massachusetts. You needed to make a sport that would have the same amount of, require the same amount of speed and effort
and would tuck them out like soccer or lacrosse or rugby. You also needed to make sure that it wasn't so rough that they could get hurt and you wanted to make sure that it was a team sport. Okay so those were his tasks. So first he drew on pieces that he could sort of essentially steal from sports that already existed and so sports like football, soccer, he says okay what we'll do is we'll have two teams and they have to get a ball into some kind of a goal but you know he said look we can use the ball like us like what you would use in soccer, but you know, they can't use, they can't use their feet and all that. They got to pass the ball.
So he was able to get a lot of his pieces just by stealing from things like soccer and lacrosse and rugby. But the main hurdle that he had to then cross is, how do I create a game that can be played indoors that's competitive, that's going to feel really competitive and hard to achieve, but at the same time safe? And so now his experience with another sport, which most people hadn't heard of, it was like a sort of hobby sport that very few people played at the time, which was called Duck on the Rock, where you would have to throw a stone and topple a stone off of a bigger stone so it would fall into the water.
Now, in his case, what he's thinking, okay, well, what if I use a peach basket? And that is exactly what he used in the original game. And what we're going to do is we're going to use the soccer ball and throw the soccer ball such that it has to fall into this peach basket. And essentially thus was born basketball. One thing this suggests though, and it's striking as you talked about his process, his process was not just you know, I have a task, I've been set a challenge, I'm just gonna sit inside my head
and try and figure out this challenge on my own. He actually looked at everything that he knew from his past life. He looked at examples from soccer, from rugby, from lacrosse, and he recombined them. And it's worth pointing out that in some ways, I think we have this illusion that the inventor is the person who sits in a room by himself or herself and comes up with a genius idea. This paints a very different
picture of it Sheena. There's only so much you can do with the pieces that you have in your head, right? You can take the pieces and you can scan your mind for all kinds of prior experiences and you know, you might get lucky and remember something that you hadn't earlier thought to use. But chances are if you're repeatedly stuck, it means there's a piece you're missing. And that means you gotta start searching outside of yourself to find that missing piece. You see that besides the capacity to observe the world carefully, multiple studies have found that creative people tend to have one personality trait in common. Can you talk about the power of curiosity?
Well, curiosity is the trait that is most associated with creativity. And the reason why it's such a powerful force is because when you're curious, you start searching in lots of little corners for things and you discover all kinds of unique bits of information that can be helpful when you're trying to get a new idea. I returned myself recently from a visit to Paris where I went to the Louvre and I fought through crowds to get a look at the Mona Lisa. You say that the painter Leonardo da Vinci is one of the most iconic examples of curiosity driving creativity. How so? So this was a guy who, you know, clearly is most famous for things like the
Mona Lisa and the Last Supper. But what he did was he just kept studying stuff. I mean, it was like back in the 1500s, right? And yet, you know, he's studying everything. He even would take dead bodies and try to examine the anatomy. He, if you look at his notebooks, he essentially was so interested in all kinds of things that he began to make rough drafts of drawings that sort of are like robots and helicopters and driverless car. In fact, the first driverless car that was showcased
in New York City, in Manhattan, in fact, in the early 1900s, it was a failure at the time, but it was building off of some of the original drawings by Leonardo da Vinci. So he was very much a polymath. And in some ways, I think one of the things you're pointing to, Sheena, is that when we're searching for a solution, it might not be sufficient just to look in the domain in which the problem exists. Part of what made Leonardo da Vinci so successful was he was voracious in terms of where
he was looking for ideas. He didn't care about limiting himself to one particular domain. Yes. Now, you want to be careful about something, which is that we often think that all we have to do is just expose ourselves to lots and lots and lots of information bits, particularly in the modern age. Mindlessly consuming lots of random bits of information without it having any understanding of the why the what Isn't going to make you more creative
It does have to be driven by your curiosity and your curiosity the reason why it's important is Because when you're curious, you know, what question is leading you to search wherever you've searched. And that then means that you now know why you're looking at this information, why it matters, which then enables you to organize and categorize that information in your brain in a way that you can later access it. You say that persistence turns out to be another driver of creativity, and you and others demonstrate this through the use of an exercise called the toothpick test.
What is this test, Sheena? It's a beautiful illustration of a very basic insight about human creativity. If I ask you to come up with as many different uses as you can think of for how to use a pile of toothpicks, and I give you two minutes, and you'll come up with a whole bunch of ideas, typically anywhere from two to, I've seen somebody get as many as 30 different ideas
in two minutes. And then I ask you, you know, look, if I gave you another two more minutes, how many more ideas would you come up with? You know, some people might say five, six, seven, but most people will say, I've run out of ideas. But it turns out they do come up with more ideas than they expected to in the second round of two minutes.
And then if I ask them again, hey, how many more ideas do you think you would be able to come up with if I gave you another two minutes? At this point, they've really feel like they've burnt out. They've run out of ideas, they're down to zero. They still come up with more ideas than they originally predicted. Now, what's interesting here is that in the very beginning of a, let's call it mind-wandering or creativity exercise,
ideas do come to you fast and furious and it feels amazing. You're in the zone, you're in the flow, you love it. However, that's actually when you're most likely to have your most redundant ideas with others. So you're least likely to have your most redundant ideas with others. So you're least likely to be your most creative because you're just coming up with the same ideas everybody else is coming up with. As you're forced to persist or as you force yourself to persist, even though the ideas will come out in less volume, The quality of the ideas is going up. And as the quality goes up, it means you're more likely to have ideas that are less redundant
with others that are the true pearls. From medical breakthroughs to great works of art, we like to believe that creativity, invention and innovation happen in an instant, that artists and inventors draw from a mystical source of creativity and then inspiration strikes. But moments of inspiration do not necessarily strike in an instant. It's more accurate to say they are a process of gradual cultivation and recombination. When we come back, how to plant the seeds of inspiration to cultivate your own eureka moments. You're listening to Hidden Brain.
I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. The famous French sculptor, Frédéric Auguste Bartholdi, got his inspiration for the Statue of Liberty from ancient Egyptian sculptures, a silver coin, and his mother's eyes. The actress Hedy Lamarr came up with a way to target torpedoes while playing the piano with a friend. Nancy Johnson invented the hand-crank ice cream freezer using spatulas in her kitchen and a bathroom
tub. In many stories of human invention, there are common threads. Innovators take inspiration from outside sources and they remember these sources as they are combining ideas. At Columbia University, Sheena Iyengar says all of us can learn from these insights. She is the author of Think Bigger, How to Innovate. Sheena, we've talked about how even the most prolific artists borrow from others and take inspiration from the outside world.
But very often, inspiration doesn't come from the familiar, but the unfamiliar. In 2007, the researchers Lee Fleming, Santiago Mingo, and David Chen made a list of over 35,000 inventors who had worked on patents with at least one other person. Tell me about the study and what they found. You know, usually when you have a patent, it's not usually by yourself. In fact, they isolated those patents that were collaborations. And so then they asked the question, which patents are most likely to be more creative, meaning cut across multiple boundaries?
但很多时候，灵感并不来源于熟悉的事物，而是陌生的人和事。2007年，研究人员李·弗莱明、圣地亚哥·明戈和大卫·陈列出了一份超过35,000名发明家的名单，这些人曾与至少另一人合作过专利。能跟我讲讲这项研究以及他们的发现吗？你知道，通常当你拥有一个专利时，往往不是你一个人完成的。事实上，他们挑选出了那些属于合作关系的专利。然后他们提出了一个问题，哪些专利最有可能更具创造性，也就是说跨越了多个边界？
And they looked at the patents between individuals that had known each other for a lifetime, maybe even working together for many, many years, versus patents that were between individuals that we say have weak ties, meaning they don't know each other very well. And it turned out that it was the weak ties, meaning they didn't know each other very well, typically came from different worlds, they were the ones who were most likely to come up with patents
他们研究了那些相识了一辈子、甚至可能合作了许多年的个人之间的专利，与那些我们称为弱连接的个人之间的专利，也就是他们其实不太熟悉的人。结果证明，正是那些弱连接——也就是彼此不太熟悉、通常来自不同世界的人——最有可能想出专利
that cut across different boundaries, different categories, and were most creative. They were also more successful. I understand there was a similar study that looked at the television series Doctor Who. Yeah, that's a cool one of the longest running sci-fi shows, right? And so what the scientists did with Doctor Who is, you know, so the producer of shows like that typically remain constant, but what'll happen from, you know, across different series is that the directors and the writers might change. And it turned out again that when you have weak ties, those shows just did better. They were, you know, got way more interesting.
这些专利跨越了不同的边界和不同的类别，并且最具创造力。它们也更成功。我听说还有一个类似的研究，研究对象是电视剧《神秘博士》。是的，那是一个很酷的长期播出的科幻剧之一，对吧？科学家们对《神秘博士》的研究是这样的：这类节目的制作人通常保持不变，但在不同的剧集里，导演和编剧可能会换。结果再次表明，当你拥有弱连接时，这些剧集表现得更好。它们会变得有趣得多。
Why would this be the case, Sheena? Well, when you and I know each other for a while, we just create our own little, you know, echo chamber. And so unless we are actively going out to collect different experiences, And so unless we are actively going out to collect different experiences, you know, you're just gonna keep producing similar variations of the same stuff. And so if you want a new way of framing a problem
为什么会这样呢，希娜？嗯，当我和你认识了一段时间后，我们就会创造出自己的一个小回音室。因此，除非我们积极主动地去收集不同的经历，所以，除非我们积极主动地去收集不同的人生体验，否则你只会不断地生产出相同事物的相似变体。因此，如果你想要一种界定问题的新方式
or new information, it really does come from somebody that just sees the world in a different way and they have different experiences. I want to talk about another component of innovation and that is about identifying the right problem. In 2020, Stacey Boland was an engineer at NASA's Jet Propulsion Lab. She was working on a project that had her tracking different types of air pollution. At that point, COVID struck and her office shut down. And like many of us, Stacey went home. Can you tell me the story of what happened next, Sheena?
或者获取新的信息，它真的来自于那些以不同方式看待世界、拥有不同人生经历的人。我想谈谈创新的另一个组成部分，那就是识别正确的问题。2020年，斯黛西·博兰是美国宇航局喷气推进实验室的一名工程师。她当时正在参与一个项目，追踪不同类型的空气污染。就在那时，新冠疫情爆发了，她的办公室关闭了。和我们许多人一样，斯黛西回家了。希娜，你能给我讲讲接下来发生了什么故事吗？
Well, that's a really inspirational story. This was a team that was on the campus of Caltech, but they work for NASA. They go home and they're, you know, bored and they feel like they should be doing something to make themselves more useful. And every afternoon on Zoom, they're saying, okay, well, let's think about all the problems that we're seeing in the newspaper. And they would just make a list, you know, they were reading the same thing you and I were reading. You know, how do we get more masks? How do we get people to stop touching their face? How do we deal with the ventilator crisis? How do we deal with the supply chain crisis?
嗯，这是一个非常励志的故事。这是一个位于加州理工学院校园里的团队，但他们为美国宇航局工作。他们回家后，你知道的，感到很无聊，觉得自己应该做点什么来让自己更有用。每天下午在Zoom上，他们都在说，好吧，让我们想想我们在报纸上看到的所有问题。他们会列一个清单，你知道的，他们读的东西和你我读的一样。我们如何获得更多的口罩？我们如何让人停止触摸自己的脸？我们如何应对呼吸机危机？我们如何应对供应链危机？
There were all kinds of crises going on at the time. And every day they would make a list and then they would say, well, which of these problems do we think we might be able to help with? And I think that's a really important question, right? Because we all wanna help on lots of things, but they asked which one would we have the ability to help with. And so they're saying, okay, well, we do know something about breathing, right? Because they dealt with breathing in outer space. And so they say, well, is it possible that we might be able to help with the ventilator crisis?
当时各种危机四伏。他们每天都会列一个清单，然后说，好吧，这些问题里我们觉得哪些是我们能够提供帮助的？我觉得这是一个非常重要的问题，对吧？因为我们都想在很多事情上提供帮助，但他们问的是，我们有能力在哪个方面提供帮助。于是他们在想，好吧，我们确实懂一些关于呼吸的知识，对吧？因为他们在太空中处理过呼吸问题。所以他们说，我们有没有可能在呼吸机危机上帮上忙呢？
And so Stacey Boland was the one who led that. And, you know, it's very impressive. I mean, she didn't have any medical degrees. She did have family members who were in medicine, and she took advantage of that. And so she began to first collect a lot of information from the doctors, what parts of the ventilator were really necessary, you know, what were the stumbling blocks as to why we didn't have more ventilators available to people. And so little by little, in the space of 37 days, they were able to create a miracle. They created a briefcase size ventilator to Mount Sinai, and that was their first test case.
所以斯黛西·博兰就是领导这个项目的人。而且，你知道，这非常令人印象深刻。我是说，她没有任何医学学位。不过她有从事医学工作的家庭成员，她利用了这一点。于是她开始先从医生那里收集大量信息，了解呼吸机的哪些部件是真正必需的，你知道的，为什么我们没有向人们提供更多呼吸机，其中的绊脚石是什么。就这样，一点一点地，在37天的时间里，他们创造了一个奇迹。他们为西奈山医院制造了一个公文包大小的呼吸机，那是他们的第一个测试案例。
And it turned out that it worked. Now, you and I both know that ultimately it turned out the ventilator wasn't as important as they originally thought. But it's still in circulation, this ventilator, it's still used in remote parts of Africa. Sheena says that one of the keys to the NASA team's success was that they picked the right problem. The researcher Paul Knott at Ohio State University has done research on this issue. He and others have found that half of the ideas and strategies that companies come up with fail.
事实证明，它成功了。现在，你和我都知道，最终事实证明呼吸机并没有他们最初想象的那么重要。但这个呼吸机仍在流通，它至今仍被用于非洲的偏远地区。希娜说，美国宇航局团队成功的关键之一，在于他们挑选了正确的问题。俄亥俄州立大学的研究员保罗·诺特曾就这个课题进行过研究。他和其他人发现，公司提出的创新想法和策略有一半都失败了。
And the reason why their new strategic visions fail is most often because they end up creating a solution to the wrong problem. And they often only discover that when it's kind of too late after they've started the implementation. Then they'll realize, wait, this isn't what we were trying to do. And so it is, I mean, we underestimate the importance of really taking that time to understand and define your problem well.
他们的新战略愿景之所以失败，最常见的原因往往是他们最终针对错误的问题创造了一个解决方案。而他们通常只有在开始实施之后、为时已晚的时候才会发现这一点。然后他们会意识到，等等，这并不是我们想要做的事。所以，我的意思是，我们低估了真正花时间去理解和明确界定问题的重要性。
I mean, Einstein put it succinctly when he said that if I have an hour to save the planet, I would spend the first 55 minutes thinking about the problem and the last five minutes thinking about the solution. We really have to understand that problem well. Inspiration often involves bringing together different ideas from our past. It involves learning and memory. But things often come together in novel forms in unexpected moments. Researchers call this mind wandering, which is basically a fancy term for daydreaming. Overall, we as humans do need to do some amount of it.
我的意思是，爱因斯坦曾精辟地指出，如果我有紧迫的一个小时去拯救地球，我会花前55分钟思考问题，然后花最后5分钟思考解决方案。我们真的必须把那个问题彻底搞懂。灵感通常涉及将我们过去的各种不同想法结合起来。它涉及学习和记忆。但事物往往会在意想不到的时刻以新颖的形式汇聚在一起。研究人员称之为心灵漫游，这基本上就是白日梦的一个高雅说法。总的来说，我们人类确实需要进行一定程度的心灵漫游。
That's when we do a lot of our problem solving. That's why you often have flashes of insight in the shower when you're taking a nap or when you're doing some other sort of routinized task like exercise or cooking. It's when our minds are wandering that we're more likely to sort of naturally try out different combinations of information bits to try out different solutions. Again, your ability though to come up with a really good solution with what you have
那是我们进行大量问题解决的时候。这就是为什么你经常会在洗澡时、小睡时或者在进行其他常规任务（如锻炼或烹饪）时突然灵光乍现。正是在我们的思绪漫游时，我们更有可能自然地尝试各种信息片段的组合，以寻找不同的解决方案。不过话说回来，你利用现有的资源想出一个真正好的解决方案的能力
in your head depends on what you've got up there. If you don't have the relevant pieces, then no amount of mind wandering is going to magically give you the answer. So me just hanging out in the shower and waiting for inspiration to strike, that's not gonna do it, Sheena? I mean, you might get some ideas for a story,
取决于你脑子里有什么。如果你没有相关的材料，那么再多的心灵漫游也不会神奇地给你答案。所以如果我只是在淋浴间闲逛并等待灵感降临，那是行不通的，希娜？我的意思是，你可能会为一个故事获得一些灵感，
but if it's something you know nothing about, then yeah, no, I don't think so. What are the curious things about creativity is that we often believe that the more options and tools we have at our disposal, the better off we're going to be. Can you talk a moment about how constraints might not be the enemy of creativity?
但如果那是你一无所知的事情，那么是的，不会的，我不这么认为。关于创造力，最奇怪的事情之一就是，我们常常坚信，我们掌握的选择和工具越多，我们的处境就会越好。你能谈谈为什么限制条件可能不是创造力的敌人吗？
Well, it's well known that artists, even jazz musicians, will say that you don't wanna give people complete freedom, that creates noise. What you want is to give it constraints. And so that even when people break boundaries and go against them, they still just end up erecting new boundaries.
嗯，众所周知，艺术家，甚至是爵士乐手，都会说你不能给人们完全的自由，那会产生噪音。你想要的是给它设定限制。因此，即使当人们打破界限并逆势而行时，他们最终也只是建立新的界限。
Now when you do studies and you give people unlimited options versus just a few options, so for example there's a very famous set of studies that were done by colleagues at NYU, and you have them make paintings or scarves, it turns out that if they're given, you know, a few materials to work with, like six different materials versus like 12 to 15 materials, it turns out that the ones who were given fewer materials end up making things that are far more creative. And you know, of course, there's a long history of research that I've been a part of that shows that in general, giving people more options doesn't actually lead to all the benefits
现在，当你进行研究并给人们无限的选择与仅仅给他们几个选择时，例如，纽约大学的同事们做过一组非常著名的研究，你让他们画画或制作围巾，结果证明，如果给他们，你知道的，几种材料来使用，比如六种不同的材料，而不是12到15种材料，结果证明，那些只被给予较少材料的人最终做出的东西要具有创造力得多。你知道，当然，我参与过的一项悠久的历史研究表明，总的来说，给人们提供更多选择实际上并不会带来所有的好处
that we often associate, think it will give us. Yeah, I have to ask you to tell me again about that study you ran many years ago at a gourmet grocery store in Northern California. We've talked about it the last time you were on Hidden Brain. But can you tell me again about your famous JAM study, Sheena? Oh, sure. It was done in this store called Drager's, which is located in Menlo Park, California. It's still there if you're a Californian and want to visit. And this store in the 90s was really special because it offered people an unusual amount of variety. So like 250 types of mustards, vinegars, mayonnaise,
我们经常将这些好处与选择联系在一起，并认为它会带给我们。是的，我不得不请你再次讲讲多年前你在北加州一家美食杂货店进行的那项研究。你在上一次做客《隐藏的大脑》时我们就聊过这个。但你能再讲讲你著名的“果酱研究”吗，希娜？哦，当然。它是在一家叫德雷格的商店做的，位于加利福尼亚州门洛帕克。如果你是个加州人想去看看，它现在还在那儿。这家店在90年代非常特别，因为它为人们提供了异常丰富的品种。比如有250种芥末、醋、蛋黄酱，
over 500 different types of fruits and vegetables. And so I did what has now been dubbed as the, quote, jam study. So at that time, they had 348 different types of jam in the jam aisle. We created a tasting booth where we either put out six different flavors of jam or 24 different flavors of jam. And we looked at two things. First, we looked at in which case were people more likely to stop and taste of jam. And we looked at two things. First, we looked at in which case were people more likely to stop and taste some jam. More people stopped when they were 24, 60% than when they were 6, 40%. And then we looked at in which case were people more
超过500种不同的水果和蔬菜。于是我做了现在被称为“果酱研究”的实验。当时，他们在果酱货架上有348种不同类型的果酱。我们搭建了一个品尝摊位，摆出了6种不同口味的果酱或24种不同口味的果酱。我们观察了两件事。首先，我们观察了在哪种情况下人们更有可能停下来品尝果酱。我们观察了两件事。首先，我们观察了在哪种情况下人们更有可能停下来品尝果酱。摆出24种时停下来的人更多，达到了60%，而摆出6种时只有40%。然后我们观察了在哪种情况下人们更
likely to buy a jar of jam. And it turned out that of the people who stopped when they were 24 on display, only 3% of them bought. Whereas of the people who stopped when they were six, 30% of them bought. So people were clearly more attracted to more options, but when it came down to making a choice, they were more likely to make a choice when they encountered less than when they encountered more. There's been over a thousand studies now
倾向于买一罐果酱。结果证明，在摆出24种时停下来的那些人中，只有3%的人购买了。而在摆出6种时停下的人中，有30%的人购买了。所以人们显然对更多的选择更感兴趣，但真到了做决定的时候，当他们面对较少的选择时，比面对较多的选择时更有可能做出购买决定。现在已经有一千多项研究
that have looked at the consequences of offering, not just people, actually, even non-humans, more and more choice, and it turns out that the more choices you have, all kinds of interesting negative consequences associated with it. You know, like even crickets and frogs, the more mate options they have, the less likely they are to mate. And they don't even have Tinder and Grindr. No.
这些研究探讨了向人们——实际上不仅仅是人类，甚至还包括非人类——提供越来越多的选择所带来的后果，结果证明，你拥有的选择越多，与之相关的各种有趣负面后果也就越多。你知道，就像蟋蟀和青蛙一样，它们的择偶选择越多，它们交配的可能性就越小。而且它们甚至还没有Tinder和Grindr这些软件。没有。
So... What do you think it is about the multiplicity of choices that has negative effects on our minds? And in the context of creativity, what do you think it is about constraints that actually the multiplicity of choices that has negative effects on our minds. And in the context of creativity, what do you think it is about constraints that actually might aid us, Sheena? Well, okay, so let's start with the premise, right, that in general we have cognitive limitations, right? And the thing is, for you to be able to be creative. Think about the exercise of creativity. It requires you to have a bunch of pieces and to not only be able to have them in your memory bank in a way that you can kind of say what they are, but to be able to keep manipulating them in lots of different ways. And that means, you know, in order for your mind to be able to be
所以……你认为是什么原因导致选择的繁多对我们的心灵产生了负面影响？在创造力的背景下，你认为限制因素到底为什么实际上能够帮助我们，希娜？好吧，那么，让我们从一个前提开始，对吧，那就是总的来说我们都有认知局限性，对吧？问题在于，为了让你能够具有创造力。想想创造力的练习。它要求你拥有一堆材料，不仅要让它们以某种方式存在于你的记忆库中，使你能说出它们是什么，还要能够不断地以多种不同方式去操纵它们。这意味着，你知道的，为了让你的大脑能够
facile enough to do that, it is going to need fewer pieces. It makes me think as you're saying that, Sheena, that there are in some ways two problems. One is, we might not have enough information, especially perhaps, you know, non-domain information in domains that we're not less familiar with. We might not have all the information we need in unfamiliar domains. So that's a story about a lack of pieces that we can manipulate in our heads. But there's also a twin problem, which is we may have too many. And if we have too many, they all end up swirling around in our heads
足够灵活地做到这一点，它将需要更少的材料。当你这么说时，希娜，让我想起在某些方面存在两个问题。一个是，我们可能没有足够的信息，特别是也许，你知道的，在我们不太熟悉的领域里缺乏非专业领域的信息。在我们不熟悉的领域中，我们可能没有我们需要的所有信息。所以这是一个关于我们脑海中缺乏可操纵材料的故事。但还有一个双胞胎问题，那就是我们可能拥有太多材料了。如果我们拥有太多材料，它们最终都会在我们的脑海里盘旋
and we don't know which ones to pick to actually recombine. That's right. And in fact, when you look at the marketplace of products, there is something that's now been dubbed as featureitis, which is the products that have too many features are actually less likely to be bought. Sheena Iyengar is a psychologist at Columbia University. She's the author of Think Bigger, How to Innovate. Sheena, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul,
而我们不知道该挑选哪一个来进行真正的重组。没错。事实上，当你审视产品市场时，现在有一个被称为“功能肥大症”的现象，即功能太多的产品实际上更不容易被购买。希娜·艾engar是哥伦比亚大学的心理学家。她是《大思维：如何创新》一书的作者。希娜，非常感谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你。《隐藏的大脑》由“隐藏的大脑”传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、
Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. For more ideas about creativity and many other topics, please consider joining our podcast subscription, Hidden Brain Plus. You can access a free 7-day trial of Hidden Brain Plus, including episodes that you won't hear anywhere else, by going to support.hiddenbrain.org. If you listen to the show on Apple Podcasts, you can find Hidden Brain in that app or by going to apple.co. slash hidden brain.
克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。有关创造力和许多其他主题的更多想法，请考虑加入我们的播客订阅服务《隐藏的大脑plus》。你可以通过访问support.hiddenbrain.org免费试用7天的《隐藏的大脑plus》，其中包括你在其他任何地方都听不到的剧集。如果你在苹果播客上收听这个节目，你可以在该应用程序中找到《隐藏的大脑》，或者通过访问apple.co/hiddenbrain来找到它。
Your subscription helps us to bring you this show week in and week out and we truly appreciate your support. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你的订阅有助于我们每周为你带来这个节目，我们由衷地感谢你的支持。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。本期节目尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。